new video this morning shows evidence of
gunfire and shelling in one Syrian city
along the Turkish border just hours
after the ceasefire agreement was
announced the Kurds blamed turkey for
the violation Charlie d'Agata is in the
region and filed this report good
morning well a shaky ceasefire and a
shaky deal not everybody here is happy
about it and as for the role of the US
military there are some serious
questions about exactly how the terms of
that ceasefire will be implemented
Turkish attacks continued on the border
today breaking the so-called pause in
hostilities 120 hours five days for the
u.s. to facilitate the reason turkey
went to war in the first place the
removal of Kurdish forces from a 20 mile
deep safe zone along the Turkish border
but Pentagon officials tell CBS News so
far they've received no direction as to
how to remove those forces and there's
no change to America's own withdrawal
plan still at a rally in Dallas
president Trump painted himself as a
kind of playground peacekeeper there was
unconventional what I did I said they're
gonna have to fight a little while
sometimes you have to let him fight a
little while it's like two kids in a lot
you gotta let him fight and then you
pull them apart but it's far from
child's play for the hundreds of people
killed in almost 200,000 displaced by
the fighting and Turkish forces have
been accused by a chemical weapons
expert of using what looks like white
phosphorus against Kurdish civilians
banned by chemical weapons conventions
the US has declared a ceasefire - a war
they weren't even fighting and enabled
Turkey to achieve its primary objective
which has enraged US lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle the decision to
abandon the Kurds violates one of our
most sacred duties it strikes at
American honor what we have done to the
Kurds will stand as a blood stain in the
annals of American history now it may be
telling that turkey is calling this more
of a pause than a cease fire why five
days that's exactly the time that
turkish president air duan is due to
meet with a real power broker in this
region President Vladimir Putin in
Russia Tony all right charlie thank you
very much